I want to focus on a story that's on the
Bloomberg tournament at you've written
which basically goes through the worst
case scenarios so Greece runs out of
money what happens next you know we're
in uncharted territories there and
grease running out of money wouldn't
necessarily be the trigger the trigger
would be for something really bad to
happen probably for the ECB to cut them
off the once the banks are cut off the
government can't sell their t-bills
which is what keeps them operating after
that you're looking at probably capital
controls you're talking about limits don
withdrawals on international transfers
to for the country to try to husband
whatever cash it has after that you've
got two possibilities one they freaked
out they realize this is really not what
would they want it what we want to be
doing and ultimately the government
compromises gives in to the largely
determines demands or they say we can't
live like this they're Germans are
trying and and our euro area partners
don't want us here anymore if they don't
want us we don't want them they go off
and they start printing their own
currency or they print some sort of
scrip as a means of exchange to keep
their economy functioning probably the
euro is circulating at the same time in
all events the economy really you know
goes down the chute yeah this is like
it's a real Berg film yeah i mean you
all my deaden the euro the euro was
supposed to be forever there's not a
roadmap there's not a game plan there's
not a blueprint there's not a legal a
few years ago the ECB said it was not
legally possible hmm to leave the euro
so it's really it's guesswork at best
but you know for the people of Greece
it's not gonna be pretty yes not gonna
be good at all Silvio give us a sense of
how concerned you are and give us a
sense of how you interpret the fact that
the ECB made the announcement with the
ELA yesterday as mark Gilbert was saying
is this a sign of how bad things are
that the ECB are actually saying they
really need our help at this point hi
good morning up
it's quite important to recognize that
there is currently some good wheel from
the major European counterparts involved
in the debate and certainly the cba's
are all there but i think you know if
you want to get a global view about
what's happening we need to recognize
that there is actually a pretty strong
political issue here and that's how we
build our baseline our baseline is
basically building on the idea that the
current government is not going to be
able to agree on a script which will
ultimately deliver a sustainable
solution for Greece as presenting a list
of measures at the political level is
not sufficient to release a plan and the
disbursement we put grease back in a
sustainable path you need the technical
expertise the institutions that we call
them nowadays are certainly a very
important part in but in the negotiation
and a fact-finding needs to follow any
political commitment that the government
can take with the other European
counterparts so I think we need to talk
about model political side and we think
that the current political situation in
Greece will have to evolve a pretty
significantly for the situation in which
to improve Sofia Charlie Munger of
Berkshire Hathaway said this week you
can't vote yourself rich and he was
talking about Greece and he says okay
you can have whatever election outcome
you want but the Greek people just can't
involve themselves to be better off do
you think the Greek government collapses
over this do you think they're unable to
satisfy this this conflicting demand
between what they promised the
electorate and what they need to get the
money does the government just have to
go yeah I think they ultimately that's
the way the situation will we get
resolved and the most reasonable way we
think we can conceive at the moment the
busi de happen is basically where the
creation of a unity government right
there is clearly a demand from a
population which has also some element
of inconsistency if you like because our
understanding is that the Greek people
want to stay in the eurozone but
obviously they're not very high
we to accept a conditionality which is
imposed upon them and in order for a
step forward to be made you need a
representation of the population which
results broad as possible with the
political classes to take over the very
big challenge of accepting some elements
of conditionality which means to us that
the current government will have either
to include whoever as has a say in
reflecting the population beliefs or
eventually moving to a completely new
government which has got a unity
character so in a nutshell the answer to
your question is the problem no sir I
finish your thought and then I'm going
to pick up on it ya know so we think you
know the probably a movie towards the
unity government is the most likely
outcome in our view at the moment so
waiting the conditions for a sweet to be
discussed and accepted so mark and Jim
is this them trying to is this a Greek
government again playing game theory
right so that so they're ready they're
ready to implement the reforms they have
they have a great plan but they just
need to make sure to show the population
that they've done all their kin to turn
around the big bad German yeah I you
know that's the most optimistic view I
think it's it's what you see is what you
get the government really does not know
how to square the circle unexperienced
and it wasn't expecting its euro
partners to hold their feet to the fire
as hard as they have I think that's
that's that's exactly right and what you
see is that is that in Athens anyway the
government's inability to balance the
conflicting demands of the Greek people
which is we don't want the conditions on
the loans but we want to keep the euro
and that is you know that's an
impossible situation which and its
really am you know if you had to bet
money you'd probably say that they would
ultimately stay in the eurozone because
for people like Angela Merkel having the
eurozone begin to unwind would be just a
political you know the worst political
failure in Europe probably since the war
would just be you there's more Gilbert
said don't bet against angle Merkel guys
thank you so much for coming in at Jim
Hart Lane more Gilbert and Sylvia perut
so senior economist at Nomura